bien j'accueille maintenant j'en tiens
les messieurs
m
jean pierre monnier tout le monde jean
piat alors je dis votre âge parce qu'à
chaque fois ça scotch la terre entière
en cinq sets
elle a croisé qu'elle agit là soit 70 17
non le scotch gens bien 77 57 en
carrière
58 ah oui tu es là alors c'est une forme
insolente comme on vient de le dire vous
nagez toujours trois fois par semaine
oui à peu près tu vois ça lui oui
alors imaginez km par jour bowles oui
maintenant j'ai ralenti un petit peu de
football
ouais pas de tabac n'ont pas d'alcool
non mais attendez moi je vous pose la
question
non mais parce que vous acceptiez de 77
ans en fumée une sentir la tension
jusqu'à 40 selon jean piat oui c'est
gentil pardon c'est appréciable et
l'amertume est arrivé à l'est d'accord
ça me laisse 10 ans du tabac du tabac
oui ah ouais voilà que saclay cinq ans
et alors là que j'avais bu beaucoup
d'alcool ah non là où les nuits qu'il a
raison mais j'aime bien le vin jeune
bien tout ce à quoi les gens il a pris
une cuite il avait 6 ans ont soulevé
encore oui à la bande blanche gens vous
publiez donc chez plon je vous aime bien
monsieur guy boucher comment on fait
quand samba qui montre l'exemple saint
jean ok je sais bien je manque un
exemple
donc je vous aime bien monsieur qui
trichent chez plon vous adresser
directement à sacha guitry pendant
pratiquement tout bouquin par quelques
anecdotes
alors en fait notre objectif est que ce
bouquin c'est de rendre justice à sacha
guitry sur les femmes sur la
collaboration
alors d'abord parler de la collaboration
ça vous intéressera jean paul rouve la
collaboration puisque vous êtes un
collaborateur dans le film j'adore la
collaboration moi je suis fasciste de
père en fils en fait on fait un truc
nazis comme si justement utiliser
fallait ouais ça allait aller
quel est votre occupation favorite
vraiment en occupation allemande
l'été il dit s'appeler quatre ans très
occupé alors les tiennes d'une chose
mérite quand on l'a accusée d'avoir
encore prise officiellement fait
également les fallait pas les laisser
après aussi j'ai pas été très hésitante
alors sacha guitry donc été arrêté le 23
août 44 par les ffi
pourquoi il a été arrêté alors parce que
à gueuler s'est lui-même ne le savait
pas il y là il a vu le jour à petit
accidentellement motifs de l'arrestation
ignorer donc on est en réalité il
représentait aux yeux de beaucoup une
image précise et prestigieuse
donc les représenter les gens qui
pendant la guerre alors que d'autres
souffrent et continuent à vivre dans le
guépard est d'une certaine façon c'est
ça qui la glande et loire il a repris
son métier si vous voulez très très
normalement parce que le bhl pétain le
16 juin a dit à la france entière et
marshall pétain c'est elle a l'autorité
la plus importante
à cette époque là où la france était
complètement à genoux pétain dit au
genre prenez votre travail rentrez chez
vous donc y rentrer chez lui c'est à
dire à paris les tags à dax pour soigner
ses rhumatismes
il rentre chez lui reprend son travail
c'était quoi elle a été le théâtre ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que jean paul dans
le dans le film à un moment vous êtes un
écrivain raté exactement où vivait le
chez le charcutier jugnot enfin mes
jambes bien vitry et vous rencontrez
vite fait et là c'est mon maître m'a
évidemment et vous essayez de
de prix auprès de lui mais ça marche pas
du tout et je me fait rabrouer guitry
est collé en taule ses films ses pièces
et lille sont interdits ces contrats
d'édition sont dénoncés par dans la
maison plan c'est marrant mais ces
cantons banques sont bloqués pendant
trois ans et combien de temps il reste
en tout là bas ils restent en taule 60
jours faisaient que c'est pas très long
mais avec deux mois de prison c'est tout
même pour un homme qui avait tout les
trucs tout le monde à ses pieds le monde
parisien le monde mains d'étrangers
c'est une humiliation énorme il a pas il
n'a pas 18 ans des as époque là il a un
grand 40 ans 44 il a déjà 60 ans voire
avant
donc c'est une mue c'est une chose très
dur à subir et le subis pendant 60 jours
ensuite ya un non-lieu il dit quand il
l'apprend le non lieu il ya un faux nom
n'y avait pas lieu oui il ya un premier
en liant 45 y en a un autre en 47
ouais alors bon il a un mot merveilleux
l'espoir c'est bien qu'il n'y avait pas
le même dit reid et non lieu mais moi
y'a un truc qui m'énerve un peu quoi
c'est que le mec il a vécu il a vécu
bien et c'était tranquille pendant la
guerre et qu' il est un peu d anvers
dans libération c'est pas très grave
un soin vos des travaux mais pour lui
c'est très grave parce qu'il n'est pas
mauvaise et injuste
d'abord il est réhabilité c'est une
preuve tout même d'injustice non parce
que boost il a été réhabilité
non non non non non non ça n'a aucun
rapport non vous pouvez par mélanger
brusque et éditrice concernant mais ce
que veut dire jean paul c'est vrai que
les gens qui ont mené la bonne vie
pendant l'occupation et pendant que
d'autres étaient dans des sens et est
prisonnier crever de faim sénant
puissions emmerder à la fin de la guerre
après tout va pas les places acquises et
bien écoutez c'est un point de vue belle
je ne sais pas prévu que je ne
partagerais non excusez-moi mais en 40 à
être pétainiste c'est pas très grave
c'est c'est mitterrand et et on peut
comprendre moi je vous comprends très
bien on peut être dire c'est ces voix là
on fait la paix et pétain ses sauveurs
de 14 et tout va bien mais on arrive en
42 là on se pousse un petit peu des
questions mais non et moi je comprends
pas je rencontre les gens qui restent à
paris et comme guitry qui était vide
un qui vit bien paris et qui comprend ce
qui se passe et qui comprend
l'occupation allemande
il ya la ministre qui arrivent il ya
tout ça et on attaque
oui 43 d'accord un an après et moi je
comprends pas ça moi je crois je serai
pas là n'est pas envahis par la milice
constamment les gens n'étaient pas sûrs
c'est par la musique on ya les allemands
il y avait des jambes il y avait une vie
normale professionnels ont écouté ses
griffes y essayer je veux dire c'est que
je comprends que les gens qui les
guidera avait épousé une autre
profession que celle là on ne parlerait
même pas de lui à l'heure actuelle or il
aurait fait exactement la même chose
dans une profession qui elle n'appelle
pas la médiatisation vous savez bien
comme il y avait une vie mondaine
parisienne où ont fricoté avec les
villes voisines avant il était l'homme
de cette vie mondaine parisienne avant
les événements et pendant et après après
les témoins d'ailleurs mais il n'a pas
bénéficié de l'occupation pour devenir
quelqu'un d'important c'est ça que je
voudrais bien failli surprendre
non ça c'est vrai tandis que d'autres
sont ces se sont servis de l'occupant
des et là ce sont des collaborateurs
parce que la collaboration fall allant
tout cas l'occupation les asservissent à
lui où vous dédié ce livre alain decaux
qui est un ami à vous en faites vous
allez rencontrer un agent son ensemble
voilà il vous rencontrer à la même
époque en 44 à la fin de la guerre la
future épouse d' andré castelot mais qui
vous fait entrer d'une certaine façon à
carrière en voulant rentrer dans ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque les tournées
barré s'est détournée qui fait tour de
france tu vas bientôt connaître ça
laurent il est tourné bars et les gars
là car saint tite ça c'était les gens
qui tournent dans toute la france est
alors en 1945
vous jouez à vichy et au casino de vichy
vous rencontré celle qui sera votre
épouse françoise en gueule et elle vous
présente jacques charon et puis voilà
après le devient donc votre première
épouse est on si vous restez 25 ans à la
comédie française qui est très long vous
quittez un jour en 72 et quand vous
quittez la comédie française
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
acteurs vous fait un triomphe avec will
tournant de françoise dorin
j'ai une chance et à une pièce qui
évidemment se joue 900 fois c'est une
matière away papa pour pas pour battre
pour davie est est ce que est ce que
vous dites du bien de la comédie
française parce que c'est à dire jamais
de mal de l'institution comédie
française parce que l'institution elle
même est remarquable les
les hommes seraient ce les hommes et
quelquefois bien dans ceux qui habitent
cette institution ont quelques
défaillances mais l'institution elle
même ses remarques
c'est un fait rare trouver des gens qui
disent du ghana comme le dit pas mais
non seulement il dit du bien jean piat
mais il voudrait qu'on tombe bien joué
les classiques comme on les joue en
disant si vous voulez jouer les
classiques d'une autre façon il ya plein
d'endroits mais vu que ce un théâtre
subventionné joué les classiques d'une
façon classique
pour moi c'est la carte de référence
devrait être une référence pour les
classes et qu'on les joue ex ante d'une
façon afrique dans d'autres lieux oui
mais là non essayer de trouver une
formule qui soit valenciennes votre seul
regret c'est de ne pas avoir fait plus
de cinéma oui une certaine façon un vous
ai fait de la télévision beaucoup
lagardère les rois maudits effectivement
8 on n'a pas le droit à tous les destins
non je crois qu'on n'a pas droit toutes
les chances oui
c'est montmagny
lula